bei all dem genörgel meine damen und
herren wollen wir bitte nicht vergessen
in diesem jahr gab es auch wunderbare
momente voller hoffnung zum beispiel der
niedergang des hc strache in österreich
unser sie posterboy lassen sie es mich
poetischer sagen die verkniffene vix
vorlage aller populisten hat seine
karriere auf ibiza spektakulär versinkt
steht im ruf des eigenen penis folgend
vor versteckter kamera randvoll mit
wodka redbull einer russischen
oligarchen nicht die kronenzeitung
verticken wollte ich sage ganz ehrlich
ich fand verstehen sie spaß immer
scheiße aber die folge der regen
warum haben wir deutschen so was nicht
man versuche sich vorzustellen dass
kanzlerin merkel oder der kanzler scholz
besoffen auf ibiza hocken und die
deutsche republik an russische
oligarchen verhindert die haben beide
schon wieder zeit zu laufen und dann war
die oligarchen nicht die ja auch noch
falsch dabei hätte inspektor strache den
fall um ein haar gelöst hat einmal
gesagt dass exakt falle das eine falle
die füße die frau hat schmutzige
fußnägel und eine russin in der liga die
hat gleich mutter gefunden
da steht seitdem im handbuch des
notgeilen populisten bei vermeintlichen
reichen [ __ ] immer erst nägel
kontrollieren ganz so sieht nämlich eine
echte oligarchen nicht aus wie heißt du
denn schätze madonna für mich reicht
aber mit dem red bull vollpfosten für hc
strache europa vor allen den geologen
noch mit einer kleinen fuß nagelfeile
zum austragen
unter den notstand
hier ist ein wunder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo
ich bin hartz iv
[Musik]
mach gradl aber wie zu hause schon
geschossen
du kriegst mailand und dafür kommst du
zu mir rüber bis und nick nack ist die
hand ich bin kurz warum auch nicht
das ist so verstehen
[Musik]
liga nicht
die st
[Musik]
die gäste
los
[Musik]
da wird mir schlecht
[Applaus]
report
[Musik]
[Applaus]
monaco und nizza
ich nicht
die hat da wirklich mitgeklatscht denkt
man darüber nach
ja der goldene vollpfosten 2009/10 und
jetzt verrate ich ihnen meine insider
geschichte leider holen die allermeisten
unserer preisträger ihren posten gar
nicht persönlich bei uns an
warum auch immer liebe zuschauer
deswegen schicken wir die dänen mit der
post wir schalten wir live in die zdf
poststelle auf dem mainzer lerchenberg
dort arbeitet neuerdings ulrich von
heesen und gernot hassknecht ich straff
versetzen musste wegen eines vorfalls in
der zdf kantine wenig in italien die
details gehen aber jemand saß nackt in
einer lasagne jungs wie läuft es denn so
bei euch gerade die persönliche auszeit
sahen hier welche die widerliche starts
funk note hoffentlich platzt der bald
sein vetter abonnenten jack 100 die
karte ist mir der ist gar nicht welche
er geht an luke mockridge absender eine
gewisse andrea kiewel wohnhaft
fernsehgarten mainz die habe ich schon
als kind gerne geguckt jungs eigentlich
sollte er da was arbeiten unsere
vollpfosten verschicken sich nicht von
alleine sklaventreiber der muss noch
ausgeht dann markus söder für den
radikalsten image wechsel des jahres
vorne bayern und hinten grün
der sänger ist im alter ego geworden
also gewissermaßen sein alter ego was
eine miese landtagswahl für denkprozesse
auslöst jetzt lässt er ständig so bilder
von sich machen wo er ohne schuldige
bäume sexuell belästigt
sie können den weg laufen china ist
klarer fall von tri tue und er hat
einfach den geilsten insta account von
allen mit ganz intimen einblicken in
söders alltag wirklich toll
hh guten morgen 70 an meinen
schreibtisch ein staatskanzlei
hallo guten morgen mit dem zug von
nürnberg in münchen
ich sitze man grob in ihrem tierheim in
nürnberg ich finde sie gerade in
nürnberg des kinderheims schön und im
zug
es ist schon eine spannende zeit total
spannend ich hatte jetzt dann was
zwischen den zähnen das war spannender
so hier das ist der vollkosten für
söders koalitionspartner hubert aiwanger
von den freien wählern
er redet noch so wie ich mir einen
echten bajuwaren vorstellen wir sind
schlicht aber nicht lassen ist eine
überlebenshilfe
aber es ist ein lachen lachen lassen es
wieder so an dass lobbyismus einlaufen
in meinen augen soll niemand das abitur
bekommen wenn er keinen orgel in britz
schlagen kann ich bin überzeugt bayern
und deutschland wie ein fächer wie jeder
anständige mann und medium stelle
gebraucht am nächsten an porsche halten
dürfen haben dürfte besser gegen gewalt
mal was ganz anderes dann kann jeder
anständige deutsche endlich mit dem
messer einen nagel in die wand einlochen
ja was hängt haben das sind original
ferkel kröten unser kabinett hat zwar im
februar endlich ein tirol label
beschlossen
aber die teilnahme ist freiwillig und
könnten schreddern bis 2019 genau so
weiter gegangen wie ferkel kastriert
ohne betäubung dazu hat die medizin
gerade was total überraschen dass
herausgefunden wenn ich ein ferkel
völlig ohne narkose gast er verspürt ist
ganz deutlich schmerz das wissen wir
heute sehr genau das ist
wissenschaftlich evaluiert jedoch einer
der apa abreifen tut weh
hättest du das gedacht schicken wir
julia klöckner hochverdient
sehen wir uns gar nicht schlecht apropos
lecker guck mal hier
hier haben uns fans einen fresskorb
geschickt und schreiben hallo heute show
vielen dank für die unfaire
berichterstattung liebe grüße eure firma
will die wurst nebenan läuft die
legendäre zdf weihnachtsfeier und wir
dürfen hier weiter buckeln vielen dank
auch welche nachricht auf diese
lerchenberg partys sind meistens total
spießig wir hatten das gesamte team von
heute schon mal guten tag könnte ich sie
für ein abo des heute show youtube
kanals begeistern schließt gefälligst
ein abo ab sofort